let's invite Luke from Michigan to speak
today Luke from Michigan uh tell me what
is on your mind today I would love to
hear from you
hey David can you hear me yeah what is
was that a chinchilla in the background
what was that
oh no that's my desk chair oh that's
your chair oh my goodness I thought it
was an animal
no
um
I'm a long time caller uh or not a long
time listener first time calling
beautiful uh I didn't really have a
question oh to be fair I was just kind
of like listening in
um
well can I ask you a question
go for it how did you first stumble
across my content
um
I want to say you were
um
I saw some videos on YouTube and then
also I watched your live streams of like
the uh Trump rallies
oh okay so mostly basically YouTube was
the platform where you came across the
content
uh yeah that's correct and let me ask
you this this is just like kind of a
focus group
once you've found the content on YouTube
did you consume content anywhere else
like did you then say Oh I might follow
and watch your Tick Tock videos or are
you just within the YouTube Universe
basically
uh YouTube at first but then I I found
your Discord and twitch so I followed
you and subscribed on there as well
interesting all right very good well
anything I can do to improve the show
sir
no I I really enjoy it beautiful well
good to hear from you I appreciate it
you too thank you all right Luke from
Michigan very very important
um there is a um
there is an option to request to speak
also but I'm just kind of going around
and calling different people
so we can uh we can figure out how that
all is going to work let's go to
um where are we going here let's go to
Jessica from Indiana Jessica from
Indianapolis welcome to the program
thanks I'm gonna like everyone else I've
been a long time listener but first time
caller pleasure to have you
uh two questions if that is okay sure
um So currently I'm introducing uh
Indiana local legislation
um as you might be aware of Indiana is
very much a red State and I'm currently
trying to introduce legislation to add
queer people okay crime protection laws
currently this is being drafted by um a
family friend of mine and state
representative Renee pack okay
um I believe to my understanding this it
is being drafted it has not been
introduced should I be preparing some
sort of like speak to talk to the
Indiana House
uh when the bill has been introduced I
have absolutely no idea unfortunately
Jessica I don't know the specifics of
the process there I just wouldn't be
able to advise you on that if there's a
possibility that you will be speaking it
would be your call whether you prepare a
speech
that's fair enough
um second question so you don't really
have that one
um let me see if I can try to find it
okay never mind I cannot find it
um why do you do you think it's a
coincidence that it always ends up being
the
people that uh try to get queer books
and stuff of that nature banned from
schools that end up being
um caught having uh predatory issues
when it comes to like well it's not
always the case it's not always the case
but there is certainly a history of that
where some of the most fervent
homophobes end up being gay for example
but I I don't know that I have any
broader you know I'm not sure I have
anything else to say about it but we've
covered a number of cases in which it
has happened certainly
okay awesome that's all I really had all
right great to hear from you Jessica
from Indianapolis great to talk to you